to the artist books are books in general
they're kind of hard to define but here
at MIT what we've defined them as for
the sake of our collection is a
contemporary form of art in which
artists or a group of artists take the
codex or book form and just play with it
however they like when that could be in
form structure or content artists books
can provide another way in - material
can provide another way to engage with
with dialogue or with historical events
or with scientific discoveries in a
visual and tactile way that can be
lacking in the classroom I'm looking to
to collaborate with faculty and bringing
them into the classroom and getting
students to really just experience them
because you know I can talk about them
all day long but if you don't see them
if you don't touch them you don't play
with them yourself then I could just
talk and it wouldn't mean anything
because you see all the work that the
artists have put into it and I'll take
care of the thought it's really just so
detailed that it's amazing it's it's
indescribable
these books are pieces of art but also
really influential pieces in the
dialogue of society and the potential
for them is unlimited so students can
create their own arse books they can
make their own works based on whatever
matters to them right now really the
possibilities are endless
[Music]